伸びてる会社の経営者の方っていうのは
ちゃんと学んだかどうか置いといても
おのずとそういう思考が頭の中に
出来上がってるんですけれども会社の中に
はまず経理スタッフレベルの本当にこう
貴重とか決算書を閉めれる方とかですま
それを責任者である経理マネージャー的な
方から予算とかに落としていったり事業の
こう成長に向けて管理会計的なですね断り
できる管理部長的な方うんうんなるほど
あとはその銀行とかあの投資家から資金も
調達してきたりそういったもイ外向けの
ファイナンスですね上場してガンガン資金
調達をしますM&Aをします海外の機関
投資にこうIRとかもしますっていうとこ
になると本当の攻めのcfoが必要なん
ですけどうんはい
はいえ皆さんこんにちはえアチーブメント
の青木です今日はですねえ国見賢介さんと
いうですねえ今日本で1番会計士を育て
えこの会計のですね育成に関しては最も
実績のある若きもう経営者また教育者の
ですねえ大切なま今も友人として付き合っ
ている国さんをゲストでえお招きしました
さんようこそ来てくださいましたありござ
本本当にありがとうございます忙しいね本
にありがとうございます今年で創業何年な
んですかえっとですね弊7月末決算でうど
決さんがあの今期のあれそれで23期目が
終わりまして今度244期目に入っており
ますはい23学生企業家としてはい元々
えっと慶王にいた時にはいはい大学の時
起業したのそれとも卒業してすぐ起業した
のあ卒業してすぐ企業っていう形ですね
はいはいそうすごいそしたら22歳企業
23歳そうですね23歳になりますえはい
ちょっとどんな風にして今の日本一のはい
その企業
はい会計人育成のね日本一の実績を出せる
学校にどういう経緯でなってきたのか
はい大学時代にですね公認会計士は取り
ましてその後はあの1年半ぐらいあの公認
会計士の育成のアルバイト学生時代に
アルバイトをしてまして合格する方とし
ない方っていうのがやっぱりこうどんどん
目の前に現れる時にま私からすると
ほとんどもも差がない皆様がうんうん
なんかたまたまそのいい先生に出会えたと
かいい勉強仲間に出会えたとかあと
スタートの時にしっかりカリキュラムの
復習をしてスタートダッシュに成功したと
かですねなんかそういったあのことの
積み重ねで合否が大きく分かれてしまって
いるなっていう気がしてですねもっと
ちゃんとやればみんな受かるのになって
いうのがすごく思ってですねそれであのま
日本一合格しやすいスクールを作りたいな
と思って最初はもう本当にその個人塾
みたいなところで当然教材の質とか講義の
質とかっていうのはやっぱり大手の
スクール様に勝てない部分っていうのが
ですねそれはあの校舎施設のクオリティと
かもですねただやっぱりあのその中でも
あの優位性を出せるのやっぱり徹底的に
フォローするっていったよなもう全ての
科目ですね科目もこう毎日なんかもう受付
の最前線みたいな私も座ってもう徹底的に
こうフォローするとかですねうんあとは
やっぱり小さい規模だったからそこ起動性
を出せるところもあってですね普あの
やっぱりこういった格の予備とかま大学事
の背テストみたいのがあった時にやっぱり
すごい人数が受けるので返却まで23週間
かかってしまったりするんですねそれを
もう試験が終わったらその場ですぐ採点し
てすぐ返すみたいなそうするとすぐ復習も
できたりとかっていうなるほどま小さい
ながらであのより高い価値を出せるところ
に最初は集中しながら教育っていうのは
あのあんまり規模を広げないでうんあの
やっぱりま究極マンツーマンでしてるのが
1番質が高いと思ってたのでやっぱ規模
広げすぎると質が下がってしまうって思い
もあったんですけれど合格者も当時で
やっと100名に行くかいかないかうんな
ので会計士の合者全体が1500名600
名の中で100名ですのでその辺でやっぱ
大きく考えが変わってやっぱりこの業界に
よりもっと大きなインパクトを出したり
受かった後の環境とかにもいろんな影響を
与えていくっていうことを考えた時にやぱ
100名しか合格者を出していないと業界
全体のインパクトってのはすごく弱くて
ですねうんうんうんそこからも規模の拡大
を目指そうと思って舎を全国にこう展開し
たりっていうのは2017年ぐらいから
スタートしてあそうなんだそっから今何
箇所ぐらいになったんですか今ですねあの
ちゃんとした大きい校舎は全国に5箇所な
んですけれどもそれ以外にあの自習だけ
できるスペースみたいのがプラスで全国に
10箇所ぐらい作ってですねはいはいそう
なんですね展開をしてきてであのその展開
をしてる過程であのアメンさん青さんとも
応援をいただいてですねはいだよねはいで
この3年間は徹底的にあの学ばせて
いただいてもう最事項も3年間で今多分
67回させていただいてはいただ本当に今
まで経営でなんだろうな無意識で大事にし
ていたことっていうのがやっぱり青木先生
の講座をこう受けさせていただくとま論理
的に全部整理されていてあそうだよねそう
だよねっていうところがすごくあの
やっぱりこう心に入ってきたっていうのと
あとやっぱりこう文字でしっかりそこを
またこう伝えれうんことによってあ知って
たけどつい最近は忘れてたなとかですねあ
知ってたけどあもっとそこを徹底してやる
ことによって大きな成果が出るなっていう
のがやっぱりすごくうんうん再認識させ
られてそこからやっぱこれを定期的にこう
自分自身が学び続けないとなっていうのは
思いながら最近は過ごさせていただいて
おりますなるほどはいハーバード大学のね
まさにこう研究とか川財団の論文にもある
んだけどうん人生における成功も失敗も
85%はその人自身の心構えの結果であり
まそこから生み出される人間関係の質と量
とはい相関関係にあるとはいえまさに僕は
国見さんという人はなんだろうその紳士に
はい本当に仕事に打ち込んでうん本当に
真心を持って目の前
のま
に接していると本当に僕お世辞の時にそう
思いました
[音楽]
はい簿記3級とかはいね2級とかあれ全部
無料にしてるのあれなんなのオンラインで
あれすごいよねそうですね戦略的にすごい
じゃないあれみんな無料で勉強したらオス
と会計士のね分母が大きくなるじゃない
ですかま今ご紹介いたいたCPラーニング
というのはこれも本当23年前にスタート
したサービスで2級1級とあいろんな経理
実務実務講座無料で公開してるんですけど
やっぱりその根底にはですね多分
アチーブメントさんの言葉で言うと
やっぱりパワーパートナーっていう言葉だ
と私は思ってるんですけどじゃみんなが
ハッピーになる絵っていつも何なんだろ
うっていうのは考えてる時にじゃああの
CPラーニングって無料の
プラットフォームをですね最初はま月額
980円とかのま最近ね流のサブスクと
かっていうのも当然色々検討には上がった
んですけれどもやっぱり月額980のうん
にするともしかしたら会員が1万人ぐらい
で止まってしまうような可能性もあるなと
思ってですねそれであればもう完全に無料
で公開してま今は50万人なんですけれど
も50万人なったのこの3年でしょだって
そうですねはいすごいねいいええ2
100万人の会計人材の方が我々の
サービスを利用していただけてればですね
おのずとそっから一部は公認会計士とか
USCPAとかていう資格をやろうって
いう方も出てきますしさはうん人材の方が
こう底上げされているとまたその方たちが
こうまいざ転職をする時とかにご支援し
たりですねあとは企業様側からも会計人材
採用するならCPAにお願いすれば必ず
いい方をっていうようななんかそういう
循環ができるなっていうこうま絵を
イメージしてですねまそこ最初は車内でも
え全部無料で行くんですかていうですね大
反対があったんですけれどもただやっぱり
そういうこうみんながハッピーになる絵っ
ていうのをあの考え続けた時のま1つの
ちょっと具とうんしてあのCPラーニング
ていうのはうんうん誕生したかなと思って
おります晴らしいえいえいや私も3日間の
研修をねもう30数年やり続けてはいはい
あの本当にもう延々とやり続けながら今ま
弟子も育ててトレーナー育ててえ6万人
以上のね方が受けてくれてるんですけど
はいこの6万人になった背景ってはい最
受行システムてあるですよはいでこの最
事項を
3日間3万円でそうずっとやり続けたんだ
よねはいであるプロのコンサルタントから
僕は言われてはいプロコンは1時間
10万円もらえますよってはいそんな割り
の合わないことなんでやるんですかとこは
その人に言ったのはままさんと助言
ありがとうとだけどあなたの今の助言って
実は我々専門サービス業において大きな1
つのなんかこうなんっていうのかな考え
なければいけない大切なことが抜けてるよ
てうんうんそれはまず第1はまず
クライアントファーストでお客様は何を
得るのかとはいうん私はやっぱり技術を
習得してもらいたいのでうん技術の習得に
は時間がかかるから3日3週間3ヶ月3年
ということでフォローを考えたとはいもう
1つはまるまるさんは納品してる時うん
営業できてないよねとはい
営業してる時あなた納品できてないじゃ
ないつまりあなたの時間のそのあなたの
売上の限界っていうのはあなたの時間の
在庫がある意味では限界作るんじゃない
のって言ったらうんうんうんそうですけど
でもこれ専門サービス業なのでしょうが
ないですよねていう風に僕はいや私は実は
1回のうんセールスで一生の協力者を作る
うんうんこれががまさにPFドラッカーが
言う顧客の想像と保持というところから
これをアイデアとしてうん満足したお客様
は一生の協力者になると思ってそういう
サービスを展開してきたんだって言ったら
はいうんそうなんですかて本人は最後まで
わかんなかったみたいなんだけどでもそ愛
通じるよね損して得とれでしょ言うなれば
はいそうですねであの本当に
アチーブメントさんの当然その講座の神は
もちろんなんですけどやっぱり私その最
受行システムが本当にすごいなと思って
ましてやっぱりこういったあの
アチーブメントさんの研修の内容って聞い
た時にその瞬間すごくあのうん気持ち
高まりますしやろうって思うんですけど
これが最事項がないと多分3ヶ月後には
その思いってちょっともう忘れてしまって
いるたこれがやっぱ定期的にこうま私も
ちょっと心のピットインみたいな言い方を
してるんですけどうん来ることによってあ
そうだったっていうの思い出してですね
やっぱりそれを繰り返すといつの間にか
その思考が通常になっていくでこのやっぱ
最事項のシステムがあることによってま
本当に私も学び続けて満足をするので
やっぱ周りの経営者にも出た方がいいよっ
ていうにご紹介をすごい紹介してくれてる
よねさんいいやいや本当いや本当に上場し
てる経者から始まってはいどうだろうもう
はいそれこそ関節的に言った780人そう
かし
いえいえでも本当になんか全ての経営者が
学んだ方がいいなっていう風に心から思う
のでそうれもなんか私も恩恵を受けながら
やっぱりでも我々はもう民間企業ですので
必ずまこうビジネスとしても回しながら
貢献をするって時にやっぱ本当にその高
循環がうんアチーブメントさんもすごい
あの作られてるっていうのは本当にあの
なんか通ずるところがあるなっていうの
はい私それはある意味ではお互いにその愛
通じるものそれはうん多分理念経営大切な
ものを大切にする経営はいあのまさに大美
商人は三方よしとはい売り手よし買てよし
世間よしとはいはい何を売っているのかと
いうその売り物をよく知りはい最終的にお
客様の顧客満足で着地させるというところ
がやっぱり大事なポイントだと思うんだよ
ねそうですね
[音楽]
はいまさにナバというかその連続合格者数
を更新中でトータルではいえすごいよね
これともかく223年度は
786名合格ですかはいはい100人中
7.6人しか合格しないでしょ公認会計士
はいで年間のその公認会計士が世の中で
合格してる数が1500人ぐらいいるん
ですかじゃはいはいその半分そうですね
はい少すごいね50.9%はい2人に1人
以上がCPA会計学院の出身いやだから
やっぱりこう情けは人のためならずという
か徹底したフォローだとかうんやっぱり
その学ぶ人の立場に立った学習の仕組みだ
とかトレーニングプログラムがはい実績と
なっているんだろうと思うんですよねはい
はいでま公認会計心にはなれないけれども
企業の中のまチーフファイナンシャル
オフィサーの仕事はできる会計財務面の
プロフェッショナルとしては活躍できる
そういう人材のま派遣とかそれから紹介
そういう事業に今後どんどん拡張して
いこうという風に今考えてらっしゃるの
そうですねあの元々は当然公認会計士
受かるまでのスクールででままず受かる
ために貢献したいてすごくあったんですね
でその先やっぱり受かった後も幸せそうに
生きてる合格者もいればそうじゃないはい
者っていうのもいるのを見た時にもっと
障害支援をしたいはいうんなるほどでまず
は合格者の障害支援ってとこが最初は
スタートしてましてま障害支援っていうの
は色々交流を図ったりですねまた継続的な
学びの機会を提供したりまあとはキャリア
の支援ていうものもやっていたんです
けれどもあの本当にそれはアチーブメント
さんから学び始めてからまた大きく変わっ
たところでやっぱりその後見したい人の資
がどんどんやっぱ最事項を繰り返す上で
上がっていってですねなるほどやっぱり
会計士っていうのはあの一流の資格の中で
はやっぱり特殊であの医者屋弁護士さんっ
ていうのはあの資格がないとできない独占
業務ま医者で言うと医療業務弁護士さんで
あれば弁護士とか健二様とかですねそう
いった仕事をしてる人がほとんどなんです
けれども公認会計士だけはあの資格がない
とできないのが監査とか税務なんです
けれども実はその独占業務をしてる人が
半分ぐらいしかいなくてですねはいはい
そうなんですか残り半分は例えばM&Aの
専門家であったりあとはあのKのコンサル
はいなてたあはさ言ったcfo最高財務
責任者だったりっていういろんなその資格
は本来必要ないんだけれども知識があると
活躍しやすいところで活躍してる方が
すごく多くてですねそういう意味で言っ
たら合格してない方も全然そういった分野
で活躍するもう実力はあるのでそういった
ところからたまたま合格しなかった方も
ですね事業会社の経理財で活躍していくっ
てこともできればでそのをやってたらまた
その延長でじゃもう日本のうん会計人材を
会計士とか関係なくて大体日本中の会計
人材って100万人から150万人ぐらい
いると言われてるんですけど会計士って
そのう4万人だけなのでなるほどもっと
もっとこう日本上の全ての企業様で働い
てる会計ファイナンス人材のサポートをし
たいっていう風にやっぱこれはもう受行も
繰り返しながらこうどんどんこう思考の示
が上がっていってそれでCPラーニングも
当初はですねあの本音を言うと最初
やっぱり3級2級とかを無料で提供する
ことによってうんのスクールの
マーケティングのやっぱり1つのツールに
簿記検定って毎年50万人受けるのでそう
いった方々が集まってくればスクールの
入学者も増えるよねぐらいな最初はあの
考えだったんですけどやっぱり途中から
いやもっとこれは実務講座と全部乗っけで
いけば日本中の会計人在のサポートが
できるみたいなどんどんその思考が拡張し
てったっていうのはあると思い
[音楽]
ますcfoってま英語でこう文字でま会計
の専門職ということなんだけどうんうんえ
小規模のあの事業種事業者あもうたくさん
ま今日このYouTubeをね見てくれ
てると思うんだけど規模的にはどれぐらい
の希望からそういう人を採用した方がいい
という風に思いますはいはいまあのcfo
っていう言葉とか経理っていう言葉って
すごく広いのでやっぱりその会社の中には
まず経理スタッフレベルの本当にこう基調
とかうんはいうん決算書を閉めれる方とか
ですまそれを責任者である経理
マネージャー的な方うんはいあとは本当に
その経理を閉めれるだけそっから予算とか
に落としていったり事業のこう成長に向け
て管理会計的なですね断りできる管理部長
的な方うんうんうんなるほどあとはその
銀行とかあの投資家から資金も調達してき
たりそういったファイ外向けの
ファイナンスですねなるほどで結構その
管理部長中を固める人ってあのま厳密に
わけcaoみたいな言い方をしてですねま
本当に中を固めますっていう管理もう本当
に日本語で言うと管理部長で管理部長をや
るっていうものと外向けのファイナンスを
やるっていうのが結構日本ではなんか
まとめてcfo的な言われ方をしてるん
ですけどもやっぱり上場してガンガン資金
調達をしますM&Aをします海外の機関と
しかにこうIRとかもしますっていうとこ
になると本当の攻めのcfoが必要なん
ですけどそうじゃない会社の中では本当に
仲を固める管理部長的うんうんいうのが
いればすく大丈夫だと思ってるんですね
ただ多くの中企業様ていうのは実はその
管理部長的な方が多分ほとんど
いらっしゃらずうん経理をやってくれる
社員はいますはいはいでそれ以外のことは
全て社長が見てますていうところだと思う
のでそういう意味で言うとあのまず社長
さん自身がちゃんと会計とか財務の最低限
のベースを入れていて自分の会社のこう
損益だったり財産の状況だたりキャッシュ
のうん青木先生もそういうとこてもすごく
あのなんか経営をしながら自然と学ばれ
てってるとこがあると思うんですけど
やっぱりはい伸びてる会社の経営者の方
っていうのはちゃんと学んだかどうか置い
といてもおのずとそういう思考が頭の中に
出来上がってるんですけれどもちょっと
そこであのそういう思考がないと実は会社
のお金の管理がずになってしまったりです
ねうんあの費用と投資の違いとかの区別も
なくですねなんか気づいたらあれお金が
全然足りてないみたいなで30名とか50
名ぐらいの本来社長さんがしっかり分かっ
ていれば経理をやれる社員がいればいいの
かなと思いますただよりその先行って社長
さんがもっと未来のこととかそういった
事業とかに専念をして経営に本当に専念
するようになると実はそこのお金回りの
部分をしっかり社長と同じ視座で見れる
ような管理部長的なですね人っていうのが
あの出てくるで上場するぐらいまでだっ
たらそれで十分だと思いますで上場やっぱ
してその先て意味では本当に外向けの
うんうんファイナンスとかM&Aとかも
強いcfo的な方っていうのが必要って
いうのがま少し一般論にはなりますけれど
もこしYouTube見てくださってる方
の中にどういう人が良い人材はいまその
会計人材の見極め方みたいなはいはいその
辺もプロの中のプロだからちょっと助言し
てもらえるといいかなと思うんだけどはい
こういったチャンネルを視聴してるあの
経営者の方が何を求めるかによると
まずやっぱり決算書をめるっていうだけで
あれば要は会計の知識があれば決算書は
閉めれるんですね
例えば商標がいっぱい来た時にま請求所が
来たらそれを仕訳に落とすだけいう形で
あれば会計の知識あできるただやっぱそれ
だと実はその経理担当者も自社のビジネス
全体のことは理解してなかったりどこに
課題があるのかとかっていうのが分かん
ない単なる仕訳を切ってるだけの人なん
ですねうん対してやっぱり本当にその会計
の数値っていうのは過去数値なんでそこ
から今の自社の課題とか今後のビジョンに
対してどこにもっとお金を使っていけば
いいのかとかっていう会計数値とビジネス
をつなげていく時にはぱり絶対的に
ビジネスの理解が大事なので例えば商標1
個来てもあこれはこういう取引のフローに
なっていてそこのこういう風にお金が流れ
てうんなるとかっていうのが理解できて
いくとやっぱり経営者の方に対して
ビジネスに対するうん話ができるように
なるのでやっぱ管理部長的な方をあの雇う
時にやっぱりそういったことまでできる
うんポテンシャルのある方とかそういった
ことまでできるようになりたいんだって
いうやっぱちょっと経営マインドのある方
をちゃんと管理部長とかcfoとかなって
くるとで特に市営法になると経営者と一緒
にもう未来の戦略から考えていくみたいな
ところが必要になってくるのでそこは本当
に単に経理のメンバーなのか管理部長的な
のか未来を一緒に描くCF
うんうんもそういうとこ者の皆様もそう
いった方を用する気を持っていかないと
なんか法とかっていうと本当にもう経営の
CEOとCOOとcfoでもう本当にこの
3人で経をやっていくみたいな時に意外に
cfo取る時に経営者経営の共同経営者を
一緒に取るんだぐらいな覚悟を持って取る
こともちょっと少ないと思っていて
ちょっとその役割が必要だからCを取ろう
みたいになった時に多分自分の本当に右腕
になる人をうんうんうんそんな簡単に
ちょっと面接して採用しようってならない
と思うんですよねはいなんでそう意味で
言ったらそういう所用のある方を取って
一緒にこう育てながら本当にこの人がC法
になれるかどうかっていうのは社内の出席
予想じゃないんですけど何名か取っていき
ながらあの育っていくっていうのも1つの
やり方で結構やっぱ皆様即戦力のもう
バリバリ力なる支法を急に採用しようと
するんですけどそこやっぱどうしても供給
が少なくてですね奪い合いになるの当然
そういった方がうんしっかりと取れた時は
一番いいんですけれども少しこうその前の
段階から採用して育てるっていう感覚も
大事かなと思いますね
うんうん今時代ってAIじゃないですか
はいはいで会計の分野もまさにこのまAI
色々そういうまインフォメーション
テクノロジーのうん最大活用というところ
ではいはいこういう時代の中で自分のお
仕事に多少の影響ってあると思いますか
はいそうですねまこれはもう本当に教育も
そうですし会計とか監査っていうばぱAI
の影響ってのも全ての業種が必ず受けると
思ってますうんうんで例えば今平行で言う
と教育であればなんですけどうんやっぱり
今までっていうのはその入学前の相談から
ですねあとは勉強中の日々も本当にすごい
数の質問が来ますでそれをメールであっ
たり電話であったり対面っていうので徹底
的にこうフォしてるうんですけもやっぱり
それをやり世の中にある例えば会計とかの
専門情報どんどん精にですねあの
インプットしてただインプットするだけだ
どうしてもテキスト通りのことしか答えて
くれないんですねでそれやっぱり我々講師
が質問された時ってテキストに書いてある
言葉だけで説明してなくてですね本当に
その裏側のさこれこういうことなんだよっ
ていうことを回答してる時にやっぱりそれ
で情報を食べさせるだけではちょっと表面
的な回答になるのでぱにこう日々質疑を
落している情報を全部データ化してそう
いうものもチャットGPTとか生成にうん
うん加えていくなんかそういうことが
できると本当にある程度のレベルで質問に
対応してくれるなんでそうするとやっぱ
入り口の部分っていうのは生生さんがある
程度対応してくれるようになった時にただ
その先でやっぱり本当に痒いとこに手が
届く回答ができるかとかやっぱりどうして
も我々人間ってこうやって青木先生と今日
こ対談してる時もなんか喋ったこと言語
だけじゃなくてちょっと声のトーンとはい
我々いんうん入れながらこうミやっぱ
なかなかそこまでをAIに求めるのはもし
かしたら20年後はそれが可能なのかも
しれないですけど超AIねはい今のままで
はそれは難しいのでやっぱりAIまでで
やってもらえることとその後にやっぱ人間
しかできないやっぱりこのもっていうのを
うまくこう住み分けていくことによって逆
とAがやれることがaがやってくれれば
ですねより人間はそっちの高度なことに
時間をつうんでなるほどまインターネット
が入ってきた時になんか仕事もなくなると
か言われて結局今我々インターネット
当たり前に使いながらやっぱり人間が
やれることてまだまだどんどん増えてる
ぐらいなでAIもそうやって共存していく
形になると思ってましてで会計とか感で
言ってもやっぱり単純な作業は全部Aが
やれるようになると思うんですねじゃその
先のジャッジの部分だったりもっと管理
会計的な経営のアドバイスの部分であっ
たりあと最近では財務情報だけじゃなくて
非財務情報のうん開示とかですねうんあと
はサステナビリティのものとかどんどん
どんどんそういった情報公開ってのも増え
ていく中で仕事の領域が増えていく側面も
あるのでなんかAIを恐れるってよりは
うまくこうAIを活用しながら本当にこれ
からの未来に向けて求められてる
アウトプットを組織としてどうしていくの
かみたいなものは大事なのかなとそういう
意味でも我々もAIにはこうアンテナを
張りながらですね色々トライアンドエラし
て試しているっていうところではござい
ますうん
これから会計人材のそのインフラ企業を
まさにあの公認会計士を排出するだけじゃ
なくてインフラ企業を目指していこうとし
てると思うんですけどどんなビジョンを
持ってるのがちょっと話をしてください
はいはいコテには私はもう人の可能性を
広げて人生豊かにする応援をしたいって
いうのがま私の個人の人生ミッションでも
ありそれがま会社のミッションにもしてる
んですけどただ会社としてはそれをより
具体にし会計ファイナンス人材の可能性を
どれだけ広げれるかっていうところなので
などあの分かりやすく言うと私は会計
ファイナンス人材が出してる価値をま今の
もっと2倍3倍に上げていきたいんですね
まその1つはお給料もそうですけれどもま
お給料をもう会計ファイナンス人材の平均
年収を2倍3倍に上げるまそれは結局彼ら
が社会とか組織に貢献してる力が2倍3倍
になったので報酬も2倍3倍にな
るっていうことなのでなるそこをできれば
会計ファイナンス人の皆様の可能性も
広がっていればCというと日本中の組織に
対しても貢献できると思ってるのでそう見
てとCPラーニングみたいな学びのコン
テンツっていうのを今後どんどんですね
増やしていってそれも専門知識だけでは
なくてやっぱりちょっと資業の方に足り
なめなあのリーダーシップとか
マネージメントでそういう意味では本当に
もう全資業の方がアチーブメントさんの
講座を受けると一番いいと思ってるんです
けどそは交流ですねやっぱり
アチーブメントさんのもう1つのいい
ところやっぱりこの同じ座で高い出しを
持ってるうんの皆さんはたくさん集まって
きててやっぱり口座で学ぶだけじゃなくて
そういった経営者の一緒に参加した仲間と
こう定期的にコミュニケーション取るこの
の学び合いがあるので我々もこうcfo
だけが100名集まる交流会とかそういう
のをたくさんやってですねこう人と人と
こうつなぎまくることによって何かが
生まれて交流事業ですねうんあとはできれ
ばあのその専門知識ってどうしても
ブラックボックス化するのであのトイック
のように専門知識の部分をしっかりスコア
かいしていきたい例えば経理実務300点
満点で実力難点ですM&A実務とかですね
資金調達実務IPO実務やっぱりそうやっ
てスコア化することによって採用側もいや
自社はこのぐらいのうん点数の専門知識が
ある方が必要なるほどで給食者がま自分
って今まだこのスコアだからもっとここを
学べばあもっと年収上がるしもっとこう
いう企業でも活躍できるみたいなのが
ブラックボックスじゃなくなるので
なるほどできればそのスコア化をしてあの
ミスマッチをなくしていったりもっと学び
たいというこを作っていったりって本当に
まずはこの会計人材が必要なことを
どんどんどんどんイフラ起業としてやって
いきたいただその先にはやっぱり日本って
いうのはこれから人口がどんどん減って
いくのでやっぱり海外に目を向けていか
なければいけない時にやっぱりアジアて
いうのはやっぱり人口も本当に中国インド
まで入れるとやっぱり億人とかそういう
規模感があるのでまそ意味ではアジア中の
会計人材の育成に貢献をしていく
素晴らしい日本企業もどんどんそちらに
またさらに進出せざる得ないと思います
からそこの人材供給もそうですしやっぱり
海外でしっかり事業をやることによって
やっぱり外貨をしっかり稼いでく
るっていうのが日本の国力にもなるので
本当に会計人材のインフラ企業になりた
いっていうのがまこれも本当に2年前まで
グローバルなんて考えてもいなかったん
ですけどやっぱりアジア中の会計人生の
育成とかっていうところもやりたいなと
思ってましてでそうなってくると今までは
本当に先うん我々一切外部資本を入れない
でですねま借入れもエテもせずにやってき
たんですけれどもまそのおかげで安定した
成長っっていうのは取れてたと思うんです
けどやっぱりこうスピードはいうんって
いうのがやっぱどうしても足りなくなるの
でやっぱりMANDAとかですねま海外で
やる時にまた0から全部スクールを作っ
てっていう時間がかりすぎてしまうので
そうすやっぱM&Aとかっていうの
どんどん出てくるのでと資金調達っって
いうのが必ず必要になってきてまその中の
1つとしてやっぱり当然IPいうのも選択
肢にはなりますしあとはそうじゃない資金
調達の仕方っていうのもですねありますん
でまその辺をまだ明確に絶対こうしようと
いうですけど正直数年前まではIPOも
絶対しないって思ってましてあそうなんだ
プライベートカンパニーで本当に中長期な
視点で自分たちが1番いいと思うものを
やるには外部資本を入れないことによって
重度があると思ってたんですねまそれあの
アチーブメントさんも結構同じ近いのかな
と思うんですけどただやっぱり本当に
大きなインパクトはそするとま多少その
うん自由度が少し少なくなってもやれる
ことが10倍に広がるんであればやっぱり
そっちに家事を切る方が大切なんじゃない
かなって思いが最近は結構強くなってきて
いてですねなんでもしかしたら数年後に急
にIPOって言い始めてるかもしれない
ですしていう
そうやっぱり素晴らしい経営者ですね本当
に僕は今今日こうしてねあの国見さんとね
対談をさせてもらって思うんだけど
やっぱり事業は人なりという言葉があるん
ですけどその人のうん経営はやはり経営者
事業は経営者でうん決まるとうんやっぱり
経営者の心ざしはいその心ざしがうん本当
にその会社の未来を決定していきますよね
今のお話を聞いてて本当になんか未来の
こう開かれていく社会貢献が見えますよね
あの
ま
沢がですね私も京会議の議員をやってるん
ですけど東京会議書を作られた渋沢一がね
そのま会社は個人の理至を図るものでは
なく広く人力財力を集めて社会に公益な
事業を起こすべきであるとまそういうお
言葉を残されてるんですけどなんかさん
からはそういう志しの高さを非常にあの
感じましたいえいえ今日はありがとう
ございましたありがとうございますはい
感謝し
ますこ会計集の国先生が経営してるから
CPAは今こうなってるんだなっていうの
をすごく感じる対談だったんですけどうん
お話の中にも少しありましたけどやっぱり
経営者がこの会計を学んでる会社とそうで
ない会社ってやっぱり違いが出るんですか
うんうんうんやっぱりま全てのこの経済
活動ってやっぱり数値にま特にあの損益
計算書的な数値は結構皆さんイメージが
つくと思うんですけどじゃそれがどう
ちゃんと貸借対象表の財産の状態にどう
なってるかとかあとはそれがキャッシュ
フロー計算書がどうなってるかとかこっち
がやっぱ意識がない方が多くてですねそう
するとなんだろうPLに現れ例えば借
入出金してもPLには現れてこないんです
けど現金だけ増えるじゃないですかそそう
なんか使っていいんじゃないかと思っ
ちゃったりです
ねあとま費用と投資もやっぱり全然例えば
このスタジオとかの投資もこれは別に一旦
資産に上がるもので徐々に償却していく
ものと広告宣伝費みたいにすぐ費用になっ
てしまうものってなんかその資産になる
ものだと実際でもそれはお金使ってるので
長い目に言たらじゃこのスタジオから当然
その投資以上の効果を出さなきゃいけない
んですけどなんかついPLには乗ってこ
ないんでなんかそこの意識とかも弱くなっ
てしまったりとかなんでやっぱり本当に
その数値周りの感覚って言んですかね
ビジネスと数値が繋がってるかどうかは
本当に大事なそこのベースがやっぱ会計と
かファイナンスの基礎的な考え方だと思
なんから専門家になる必要は全くないん
ですけどなんかその基礎的な流れっていの
が分かってやっぱ伸びてる経営者の方って
やっぱ分かってるんですよねえはい専門
用語は全然知らなくても頭の中でそこが
繋がってるというかやっぱそこがないと
間違った意思決定をしてしまうしそこが
ないとなんか懐語に任せすぎていて気づい
たらお金の管理がずになっていたみたいな
はいそうそうよくあるよねそういう話はね
はいいや僕もあの今客員教授して事業創造
大学院大学でねはいMBAを学び始めて
はいうんあの本当に良かったのはねあの
仕訳なんかね自分で任せっきりでやった
ことないじゃないですかでもあれ全部ね
もう1回ね財務会計を学び直したらすごく
再確認になったしま自分自身のその意思
決定そのものもま僕はお金って投資か消費
か浪費しかないっていう非常にシンプルに
ものを考えてきたんだけどまとっても整理
されただからやっぱりMBAのその収支号
をね取る取らないじゃなくて学ぶことって
絶対大事だと思うしまそういう意味でも今
ね今日このねYouTube見てくださっ
ているうんあの方々にはね無料なんでCP
ラーニング絶対勉強した方がいいしま3級
だけは経営者全員取った方がいいと僕はね
本当に内はの上に上がるのに3級取らない
と上に上がれない管理者になれない仕組み
になってるんだけどうんいややっぱり必要
だなとつくづく思いましたねうんうんそう
思いましたうん青木社長はこうそれ経験の
中で培われてたものなんですかま経験だよ
ねただねあの猿でも分かる会計用語とかさ
なんかそんなすごいタイトルの本を何十冊
も読んだよ俺いうのはねあんまりね正直僕
ね会計のことは願望に入ってなかったわけ
営業はすごい得意だったりそのま物作りだ
とかそっちの頭なんだよねはいだ会計って
ちょっと苦手意識があったんだけどでも
なんとがカバーしなきゃいけないと思って
もっと早くCPAランニング受けりよかっ
たんだけどうんそのいわゆる本だよね
ビジネス書をいっぱい読んだでそれ同じ本
何度も読むのが嫌なんではい何冊も買って
読んだって感じだそうやってまベースの
基礎知識は身につけたって感じかなだから
多分本当にこう思いの強い青木先生みたい
な社長様の皆様多分本気でいい経しようと
するとどっかでそこにぶつかるんで必ず
学ばなきゃいけないって気づくんだと思う
私は逆と営業の専門家ではないんですけど
やっぱり経営をやってるともう商品を売ら
なきゃいけないですしいい商品作って商品
会ないなん必ずそこでやっぱりもう本買い
まくって読んだり分かる方に聞いて自分の
専門部じゃないとこもなんか本気で敬し
てるとおのずと学ぶのかなとは思ってるの
でやぱなんかそこを放置していいやと思っ
ちゃうとうん何か本気じゃないから放置の
ままになるっていうのもあると思う今後
やっぱ会計とかITとか今後やっぱさらに
そこにやっぱ1つえAIっていうのが入っ
てくると思うのでAIのベースを知って
どう使いこなすのかみたいなものっていう
のは本当に大事だなっていうのもはいはい
AIも含めたアウトソーシングがどんどん
増えてる中でうんもこれでもやっぱり外注
して良いところとそうでないところもある
のかなと思ったりしたんですが国先生から
捉えるとま上昇機がやっぱり人で少ないの
で外注できるとこはしたいと思っている方
も多いと思うんですけどこの線引きって
あれますかはいえっと別に単なる業務と
かって外注してもいいですしま究極その
管理会計的なとこもそういうのの
プロフェッショナルファームさんはあるの
で外注しても全然いいと思ってるんですね
ただやっぱりそこを経営者の方とか会社の
中の方がやっぱり分かってる方がいた上で
外注してるのかもう全く分かってばITで
もITのこと社内は誰も分かってませんっ
てなってなんか納品だけ来てももうそれを
形式でしか使えないのでなのでやっぱり
そこの全部を全部社内でやる必要性って
いうのも別にないとは思うんですけど
なんかトータルでやりたいこの
パフォーマンスをどこを車内の人が
ちゃんと分かっててどの作業の部分とか
あと足りないその知恵の部分は外部の
プレショファームにあるのかてそこは無限
の組み合わせがあると思うので強引に車内
にっていうのじゃなくても全然今後は多分
中小企業様はあの結構アウトソーシングも
あのどんどん増えていくと思ってるんそれ
はあの会計だけじゃなくてもですねなので
その辺っていうのは規模に応じてあのその
ベースは外注をしながら徐々に一部内政を
ちゃんとしていく部分っていうのを作って
いくみたいな形が1つあるかなとは思い
ますねうんはいうんぱお話の中にも出てた
やっぱり経営者が未来を考えてこの理想の
会社を作るためがやっぱり描かれてないと
そうそうどこを外注してよいのかどこは
内省するべきなのかも出てこないことはい
そうですねで本当にその上で管理部長様と
かcfoを取る時はやっぱり本当に経営
チームの一員を取るんだっていううんうん
の考えでしっかり採用していくていうのが
すごく大事でやっぱその辺の方が会社に
本当にコミットしてなかったりするとはい
もう警視的な業務しかしなかったりするの
でうんうんだそこはでもあの逆言うと会計
ファイナンス業界人材業会の課題でもある
と思うんですねうんうん専門知識はある
けどっていう状態になってしまってるんで
そこをもっと変えていきたいっていうのは
私の結構いく思いでもあってそういう意味
でも会計ファイナ在は経側にもっとコミと
するべきうんに思っていてですねはいうん
アチーブメントとかだとやっぱり理念共感
型で採用するのでま専門スキルだけでは
あまり採用しないと思うんですねそうだね
これってやっぱ専門スキルがある人を採用
してきてそこに理念教官やこの一緒に営を
していくというところに巻き込んでいく方
が良いのかそれともやっぱりはいもう最初
からマッチした人を入れるべきなのかはい
はいまあのある程度時間軸を余裕を持てる
んであればもう本当に優秀で理念に合う方
を採用してしまってその方に後で専門知識
を教えていくでも全然問題ないし逆に
そっちの方がま新卒からこう幹部が出て
くるのと一緒でですね別にマーケティング
と一緒で会計ファイナンスも学べば学ぶ
だけ知識がつきますんで会計士ですら23
年の勉強でもう会計のプロの入り口に
行けるのでただやっぱりそうは言っても
やっぱりある程度あの即戦力も必要だと
思いますからその時ある程度知識のうん
ある人でただ理念に共感するただどっち
いう争方私は私が採用すんであれば知識は
入ってからでも学ばせればいいのでま
こっちの共感うんとかに人としての
ポテンシャル所要っていうところを最優先
しながら少しでもそこに対して知識のある
方を取っていくっていうのがバランスとし
てはいいんではないかなみたいなはいうん
あのまこれすっごく大事な今いい質問だと
思うんだよねうん要はね作業型人材とその
未来想像型
れるんですよ確はいで作業型人材というの
はなんだろうその未来にまパーパスって
いうか目的に対してのこう頭を使うよりも
目先の作業のことをきちっとこなすことに
焦点があってるんだよねはいで経営者って
いうのは常に未来を作り出し続けてるん
ですようんだここのところで価値観が一致
して共にっていう人をやっぱりcfoでは
ね右腕に育てていかないといけないんじゃ
ないかと思うけどねうんそうですねそこね
本当難しいところ難しいテーマだよねうん
難しいやっぱりだから経営者は人間力高め
続けていかないと優秀な人を得ることって
できないんですよはい優秀な人が存在し
てるんですでも優秀な人は優秀な会社に
集まるんですそうですねうんうんこれ
厳しいよね
やっぱり中小企業はやっぱり企業の魅力は
まだまだだと思うので経営者の魅力で
やっぱりそこきづけてそうね引っ張ってき
て育ててっていうことが必要なのかそう
うんそうですねいやでも本当木先生にもし
やっぱ優秀な方を引きつけるっていうのが
ぱ傾斜なんま広くよねパワーパートナー
結局貢献したパワーパートナーとしかいい
関係が取れないとにやっぱそういう優秀な
方もこのビジョンだったら一緒にやりたい
て思うかですしうん考えてると自社の人
しか協力してくれないのがもっと業界とか
社会に貢献するとま木先生とね私も別に
同じ会社にいるわけじゃないんですけれど
もまそういうお互いがいいものを目指し
てるとじゃあお互い協力できること協力し
合おうみたいなどんどんこうパワーパドル
が増えていきがするのでや本当にそこは
経営者が何を目指していくかっていう資と
かそういう人間力的なものっていうのは
本当に大切だなっていうのはまやればやる
ほどそこがないとなかなか組織をれていっ
たりビジネスを成して難しいうんなって
いう風に思ってますねあのねやっぱり優秀
な人ほど社会なんだようん環境じゃない
はい究極良い環境を作っていこうとしてる
んですようんうんだからやっぱりまだ下の
方に行けば行くほど利己なんだよね自分の
まず儲けみたいなそうですねうんだから
やっぱりまそのプロセスってあるんだけど
はいまできればねやっぱりこうし死を上げ
うんはいうん視野視界を高めうんうん
やっぱり社会という視点から仕事をして
いくうんそうするとCPAライニングの
ように無料でていうこれが50万人という
ものすごいこう分母をねやっぱりこう広げ
ていく本当に大きな貢献をされてると思い
ますよそういう意味では社会からあれです
よね先生が作られてるスクールも本当に
名だたる方々が講師としてご協力を
くださっている状態ができてるってこと
ですそういうことですそうですねなので
ほとそこもどうしたらこう皆さんに貢献
できるかみたいなものをやりながらま
ちょっとなんか言葉は選ばどれだけ多くの
人をこう一緒に進むあの人としてこう
巻き込んでいけるかみたいなまこう
巻き込み力じゃないんですけどもそれが
なんかね利己的なものだったら絶対
巻き込めないのではいお互いがこう
ハッピーになる絵を描きながら向こうから
してみたら多分私が巻き込まれてるんだと
思いますしてお互いこう巻き込み合ってる
みたいなこういい関係っていうのができて
くるとすごくいいなっていうのはそこを
これだけどれだけ広げていける先生の本当
にあの3年間で木先生の生き方自身が
やっぱり本当その貢献の人生をされてて
なんかまこれも受行性の方はもちろんです
けどそうじゃない方もこう巻き込み力と
いうかそれがすごいなと思ってまして本当
になんか結果出してる皆様てやっぱ本当に
そういうものをうんなんかね言わ言って
しまえば当たり前のことなのかもしれない
それをなんか徹底して自然にできて
るっていうところがすごいなっていうの
本当学ばせていただいて私もまだまだでき
てないとこたくさんあるそれをいやいや
継続的に学習しながらどんどんその力を
磨きたいなと思ってますね
はいまこれからも応援もしますしうちも
応援してくださいねもう本当毎月だって
300人400人あの経営者うちに3日間
の講座に来るので会計人材もみんなニーズ
バリバリですから本当にぜひ頑張って
いただいてはいいやいやぜひよろしくお
願い
しよ願ありがとうございまし
たDET